now when people think of iodine they
automatically think of the thyroid and
it's true that you do need iodine to
make thyroid hormones okay like t4 t3
the four and three just represent the
number of iodine molecules okay so
that's true so number one childhood
development
if the child is deficient in iodine or
the mother who's pregnant with the child
is deficient the child could end up with
a smaller brain lower mental capacity a
lower IQ and overall they just won't
develop and grow to their full potential
iodine is vitally necessary for female
reproductive organs there are many
receptors for iodine in the breasts and
the eyes in the stomach and the salivary
glands in the brain and the cervix and
even in the arteries and you can see
dramatic results when you give someone
with fibrocystic breast or ovarian cysts
a high quality c-cal product loaded with
plant-based iodine so iodine regulates
excessive amounts of estrogen and
estrogen can trigger cancer and this is
why iodine can protect against cancer
now the ways that you would be deficient
is from the diet because you're not
consuming maybe in a seafood or this
soil that the food that you're eating is
just not fortified with trace minerals
which is very common especially in
America or if you have low selenium and
then you have pregnancy and birth
control pills which in both of these
situations you're going to have a spike
of estrogen and anytime you have higher
amounts of estrogen you also need a
little more iodine to compensate
radiation can deplete your iodine
smoking can deplete it alcohol can
deplete your iodine and I always
recommend a plant-based iodine in the
form of a high-quality sea kelp thanks
for watching